[Music]
in I'm out news submitted by Moses from
London [ __ ] you that's me part of the
Atlantic Ocean do reported the Thames
river oh yes a man's just that name
rings a bell
that's all a man fed up with his nagging
wife hid in the forest for 10 years
oh I totally that makes a hundred
percent sense why look into those
beautiful eyes I never knew how strong a
woman's nag was oh my god dude because
because I think it's been a long time
since I lived with my mom I kind of
forgot and then when I started living
with a girl again but it's your fault as
to why we even nagging the whole life if
you hurt us first we wouldn't yeah
that's not even it it takes a real woman
to be I warned here sometimes like I'm
like babe you see my mom right you see
how miserable miserable my dad is right
don't don't do that
is it be miserable he looks very
cheerful and pluck my [ __ ] about that is
called time and place exactly there's
this justified nagging but there's no
justification where I wake up in the
morning and it's why did you do that
listen here [ __ ]
I just opened my eyes there's no time
and no place boy you can just wake up
and live yes you can of course he can
because we have to do with his [ __ ] you
guys give us nonverbal body language
nagging that's what the [ __ ] you guys
give up everything but we don't know
about that exactly we not do a [ __ ] on
purpose
what's nonverbal body like what is that
you like when you leave your [ __ ]
everyone we're like hey honey can you
not please leave your [ __ ] here I took
all day to clean this up mom you can
smoke this stuff away
Yeah right right did it right did it oh
right there no right there
you know what see that could happen
after I [ __ ] shower and brush my
[ __ ] teeth and then you come up hey
by the way this is what happened not
right when you wake up yeah hey you
don't know if I'm singing a song in my
hand you're interrupting my song so
that's the first time right so we'll
wait and we're like oh he came back from
work you must be tired
okay cool we'll just let you chill out
and then we have our good day now at the
night we'll be like hey you know what
next can you not do that please cool got
it we're good we go to sleep happy we
might cuddle have sex would be great
right and in the second time the third
time the fourth time the fifth time the
20th time I like to fix a lot we need to
tell you the same are you [ __ ]
mentally challenged what the [ __ ] is
going on do I have to say it in another
language but that's how we feel when we
tell you are you mentally [ __ ]
challenged don't at me when I wake up
[ __ ] see remove the whole waking up the
head love this cold any times that she
nags oh she's only not anymore this is
like the year ago cuz you guys don't
live together watch it yeah oh no a
hundred percent that's why I stay the
[ __ ] away from her for about six days
out the week you're gonna have two
houses when you guys get married get
married enjoy well the kind of cool
thing about I'm pretty sure Rooney
getting those regular arguments
absolutely difference between you guys
is that your guys's level of clean are
way different our level of clean is
exactly the same she's about the only
thing that she does complain that I do I
always apologize for now is the toilet
seat thing because I told her about the
thing that backfired on me I was like
well how about this how about we just
closed the whole toilet seat down and
then both of us can't complain she goes
perfect I was like [ __ ] I didn't want
that
I always forget to do that so she does
have a right to complain about that and
I've gotten better slowly as time has
progressed I cannot wait till you live
together like straight up straight up I
know we're gonna fight about stuff but I
think the cool thing is at least it's
not so drastic in what cleaners you know
cuz I've not just clean it's just the
way you walk yeah you get in trouble for
walking a certain way but then you get
it you get in trouble because you make
one
you in and the other shoe instead of
this shoe and this it's like it's just
some stupid simi you guys just watch I
am well me and she a barely fight but
that's like I mean we're a long distance
you know I'm saying that's the key
that's the key to love Yas don't be
around each other I mean she moves in
well the thing about is hey not gonna
lie we've like talked about it like yo
you know what do people do long-distance
marriages cuz like it could work but at
the same time yeah we know should be
moving in and we both understand that
we're very like we are very like self
dependent people and we like our a long
time you need to do our own thing so
it's like I know that there are times
when we're just gonna need to just be in
other rooms and that's okay like you
have separate bedrooms it's saved our
relationship were yeah damn yeah because
there are certain things that it has
nothing to do with fighting mm-hmm but
you don't want to blame the other person
because they [ __ ] up your sleep right
so for example there's times when she
has to wake up at 6:00 because she has
to go to the gym but then I want to
sleep in cuz I'm working till like
midnight or whatever I don't I want that
extra hour of sleep and there's been
times when I got fat
I have sleep apnea I'm snoring like a
[ __ ] she can't sleep she's
waking up three four times and she's
resenting me in the morning and that all
comes up but you know I can't control my
[ __ ] snoring right but then this is
the perfect on the weekends to prove it
you're gonna you wanna cuddle [ __ ] a
disco or like you know what I'm gonna
sleep in my bed cuz I got to wake up
early i'ma jump in real quick and we
could hug oh I'm getting sleepy
I'm gonna go on my side I know you guys
are doing you [ __ ] freaks they're like
oh I live with my mom and you live with
your mom all right you're gonna sneak
into my room and be like that it was
porn [ __ ]
I wish I was that I would try that it's
actually not like I'm a [ __ ] my
stepsister no it's not no I didn't say
that she said that I was just saying you
guys live in different houses and I'm
not gonna door open a little bit house
there you know I do know that she and I
are gonna get into a fight like fights
cuz everyday
but the difference is also once again
you guys work with your partners 24
[ __ ] 7 the truth Mariel is gone from
like 9:00 a.m. to like 10:00 p.m.
because she works that many hours so
once again like we will still have a lot
of space with each other oh man I can't
wait
the only difference is but you're
messing it up though because I'm saying
that we will fight but you guys have a
higher propensity to fight more because
you're around each other a lot yeah
that's true cuz you could take it to
work you could trim that's a lot of
interaction and a lot of like from you
know from in this relationship I'm above
you so you have to listen to me and in
this relationship we're equal and it's
just the ecologist [ __ ] at all I
already saw that happen like when we
went to Paris we were arguing about
nothing because I was trying to shoot
her you know I'll try to film her and
that cause then you wanted to shoot her
yeah and then afterwards I took the
camera [ __ ] away
we stopped by because it wasn't work
anymore so I was like I can't be around
you when I'm working cuz I will shoot
you literally yeah this man felt so
malcolm 62 years old he was either
gardener he says that they were married
for about three years and then it just
her nagging just got too much for him
because she was nagging him about not
taking so much work cuz she didn't like
the fact that he was away for so long so
he's like I'm gonna be away forever the
[ __ ] pretty much but one day like she
he just packed up his stuff he didn't
tell anyone not even his own family and
he moved by about two and a half hours
away in like a dense forest area a [ __ ]
he was living there and doing like
gardening work for people around him and
he was there for ten years so you know
this this is a common thing though like
even as boyfriend/girlfriend
relationship were if you have a very
determined man he's just has a hustling
personality right so girls get with this
guy
cuz they're like yeah he has goals he
has ambitions but you get with a person
who's always busy and you don't have
time for yourself but if you don't make
it very enjoyable every time they see
you and then you get do you like why
don't we spend more time when we do this
every time they come back
there's no good reinforcement they're
not gonna want to hang out with you
they're not gonna want to be with you
anymore you got to be amazing every
single time but what the guy is also
thinking too is he's probably worried
how am I gonna pay the bills oh [ __ ] I
don't know about this I don't like that
I got to do this I don't know I hate
fighting man I [ __ ] hate fighting I
know I hate that [ __ ] she and I just had
a conversation yesterday we're like you
know we haven't gone to a huge huge
fight in a while
you guys are about to do it yeah so it's
like she's like yeah he's been pretty
good I'm like so when we do this the
hood you don't have you know it's gonna
happen everyone's waiting little tremors
yes sometimes gotta get those a little
too Pleasant you don't say in the
morning like texting a good morning I
love you she says it right back what the
[ __ ] is going on dude like I don't like
this [ __ ] now I like my [ __ ] all the
time like haha I like it like it's just
like that bro my dad you know like he's
not he's not miserable but like he
definitely needs times where he'll just
hope you like yo ah I'm gonna come by
and and get and check on whatever right
I'm like all right cool and then he'll
come in and I'm like what's up dad
coming my spot and I just sit down
anybody your mom and she's gonna go in
like look
she's what he starts doing now and he's
frustrated I think he watched my boss
let's have him like OMG oh and [ __ ] G
does stop you know and then they be
married like thirty years you know yeah
Asian mom now you to Allah even my mom
like she I told her to stop doing this
she goes well I'm your mom so I can ask
you whatever I want because I care cause
like I understand but you can't ask the
same thing over and over she just give
me an example you told me to get my
blood checked about 12 times
in ten days if they take that much blood
for me I'm dead understand like so don't
ask the same thing over know I might I
get my check up regularly every year I
get the full body shebang thing until my
doctor says something's really bad i'ma
fix it so don't worry she goes and then
all of sudden week passes did you get
that blood work yet I'm gonna [ __ ]
kill you woman like don't nag me about
this that's why I told my mom like
anytime she ask me something like give
me 10 to 14 business days no point
asking me three times a day about the
same [ __ ] you she got time to get to it
oh you know what helps give him money
no I bribed my mom I'm like mom I'm
gonna get his money you can't say
nothing to me about no vegetables about
knowing me about me sleeping oh she
would just throw the money right back
everything wouldn't work the nags me
like a week later I gave my mouth some
money and she went on a cruise didn't
talk to her for like a month
Oh pay for her vacation yeah she did a
whole cruise in like Europe oh they
don't have reception there mom you said
she sent me email all moms do there
women cuz I don't pick up the phone so
she sometimes she calls like she let the
voicemail right even in the voicemail
she's like I saw in your vlog that you
looked a little bit pale are you sure
make sure you sleep enough I'm just like
I and then the last time she called it's
like the office to end something with
okay as a boy you might not know this
need this and you have to edit she's
like I watch your vlogs Jess looks like
she cleans up after she's not your
mother she's your girlfriend don't cheat
her I'm like it's a joke joke about it
it's we're not the blog is his next
shift frustrating yeah this is hella
frustrating huh I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
too like we're being sarcastic and Asian
moms don't read sarcasm you know what I
hear though all your little complaints I
just hear like my mom loves me exactly
oh that's what women speak the same
language you're so loved and I'm not
saying that she doesn't love me I call
my mom almost every day
United mean like we have normal
conversations I were just saying it
guess I just wish she didn't address me
like I was a three-year-old that didn't
know anything don't act like one and she
Wow like you know I like on JK news you
know how like this is how we dress my
mom calls me up she goes hey you know
you're on YouTube now she'd be a little
more professional oh my god [ __ ] you
tell me how to do my [ __ ] job and she
goes no it's because they don't have
tact they talk to you like you're a
[ __ ] lizard you know like like you're
[ __ ] dumb like a cockroach on the
street talk to my kid like that - if she
was more nurturing and said you know I
think your fans would really like it if
you put on some cool he's just gonna be
complaining about that - no but that's
probably true though well what happened
what happens when when you get nagged
like that cuz you know when you grow up
you never listen to your parents like
your parents can be telling you the best
[ __ ] and you don't want to listen cuz
you're so annoyed someone else exactly
it's someone else tells you drive it to
a beat oh right because if anyone else
tells you the exact same [ __ ] you're
like oh man they have a point you know
but you've been hearing it from your
parents and it's so annoying you're like
oh okay I'll drink milk whatever I don't
want to take the [ __ ] milk you're
alone you're like you know what I want
some [ __ ] milk you know and this will
be good for my bones
so the nagging works no daddy doesn't
work so if I'm gonna put my [ __ ] away
just shut the [ __ ] up and I'll start
putting anyway probably not no but okay
but but to your point to her to your
point to her even though I was super
annoyed of all the [ __ ] my mom would
tell me about vegetables growing up I do
now everything is in the back of my head
like I will be like that's what we do
who will be like oh you know what I
should eat these [ __ ] tomatoes cuz my
mom did say they were good for my skin
when I was like a little kid we are
brain and just we are we [ __ ]
intercept your [ __ ] mind and you
don't even know what happened to you
been a mom for one month
[Laughter]
[Applause]
he can barely hold his head up and [ __ ]
oh that's fine every picture he was it
that the most interest thing you've ever
heard in your whole entire life I don't
even know what you guys just talked
about but anyways please subscribe for
more random videos more funny content
and more hahaha poopoo in your pants
stuff go ahead subscribe and for more
videos right now